uh thank you very much indeed a good eu
nato corporation
remains a top priority of for the
commission
um we had an excellent exchange with
secretary general
jens stoltenberg and indeed he was uh
pointing out at the very different
threats and challenges
we are facing and in some cases we
address these challenges
in nato you know all the theaters nato
is in
at the moment being but there are also
scenarios
where nato is not engaged but where the
european union is
called upon so if you take for example
the eu missions
or the u.n missions and the european
union
needs to be capable to do that
therefore europe needs to develop its
own capabilities
thus stop the fragmentation we have at
the moment being
if we look at our military capabilities
and develop interoperable
systems in the european union that is
why we have set up the first building
blocks
of the european defense union it is the
pesco
the permanent uh structured cooperation
pesco is supported by the new
8 billion euros european defense fund
and it will help us to develop military
capabilities
as europeans together we have the
industry
we have the knowledge what we need is to
put this
innovation and these talents
at the service of common european
capabilities
this will reduce fragmentation and it
will enhance interoper
interoperability earlier this week
we presented an action plan on the third
component
that is important here and these are the
synergies the synergies between civil
industries
defense industries and space industries
by synergies we mean that eu funding for
research and
development in defence and space can
have
concrete civil applications
one example is the euro drone we will
identify
critical technologies across defense
space
and the civil industries we will then
develop road maps
from inception to application using
available eu funding and finally
we will apply these technologies to very
concrete
projects this week we launched three
flagship projects to test this approach
it's the drone technologies
a space a new space communication system
and
space traffic management so uh
in short the cornerstone is pesco
enabled by the european defense fund
and the necessary coordination with
in the european union takes place
through the so-called card
planning process and it's very
compatible with the nato planning
process
itself a few words on the southern
neighborhood
indeed the mediterranean region
has a strategic importance for the
european union
both our security and stability are
intertwined
as we celebrated the 25th anniversary of
the barcelona process this month
we decided to renew our partnership with
southern neighborhood countries
first of course in fighting this
pandemic
together this is why we have mobilized
over 2.3 billion euros
in support 1 billion for health and 1.3
billion for economic recovery
but the pandemic has also accept
exacerbated
difficulties in the region like economic
hardship or lack
of perspective for young people these
challenges were there before without any
doubt and
they need to be addressed in a more
structural way
and this is my second point our renewed
partnership includes an
economic and investment plan for the
southern neighborhood
it aims to support long-term
socio-economic recovery
and to accompany sustainable and digital
development in the region
under this plan the commission proposes
to mobilize
up to seven billion euros it is included
in the so-called and key the
neighborhood
and development and international
cooperation instrument it's a long name
for a abbreviation that not everybody
knows the ndk
in turn this instrument would help
mobilize private and public investment
worth
up to 30 billion euros and beyond these
two elements we will
of course continue to engage with our
partners across
the all the areas where we share common
challenges
thank you thank you madam president